there's a lot of subreddits of people
getting injured yeah i didn't realize
there's so many subreddits for like
people fighting like just mobile phone
videos people fighting right yeah people
love that [ __ ] i didn't realize people
love it
i mean like that's kind of like
i don't actively search for it but
whenever it pops out my twitter feed i'm
like
all right i got time i have 30 seconds
yeah
i like it when it's school kids fighting
i don't know why because it's so
wholesome because it's like a slapping
contest like slap each other and then i
was like
in the background it's like all right i
think there's just something primal
about it right that's why there's so
many fights
i think that's just like there's there's
a reason why like there are so many
[ __ ]
fights in clubs right because like i
wasn't civilized
exactly bro there's there's a reason why
there are so many [ __ ] fights in
clubs right because
you know you put a bunch of guys they
get drunk and they like learn
like they live on their primary
instincts so what they're gonna do
they're either gonna get horny or want
to start a fight
which is the two [ __ ] things that
happens in clubs so if they can't get
with the girl
most of the time a fight that's our
hands yeah yeah exactly you know
fair enough can't be helped logic logic
just walks into the club just starts
punching everyone
i remember when i was like 18 i got a
fight with the bouncer because i lost 10
pounds
so it was a low point a low point i like
how did you explain
how did you lose the 10 pounds so i i
yeah i went around this clubbing
so i've lost it i was really drunk i've
lost the tenant
and then eventually it's time to leave
now i've lost 10 pounds i've got to find
it
and he's like you got to get out and
then he like like grabbed me and threw
me out
like a like a toy yeah and they got back
to my apartment
she cried stripped off the ten pounds
just fell out
started a war with an entire nightclub
over ten pounds i mean
as an eighteen-year-old with no money
that was like all my lifestyle ten
yeah that's a lot you guys ever been
thrown out of clubs
luckily not i guess that time i was
fortnight dancing but that's about it oh
yeah that's about it right
i think i've been thrown out of one club
were you too drunk huh were you too
drunk yeah so this is of course this was
in university right
and uh i think i think this is like
right like not fresh this week but like
week two of freshers week
and of course you have you have the
pre-lash right you get you get drunk
and you know back when you're [ __ ] 18
you don't [ __ ] know your limits yeah
you just you just drink as much as you
want right lose a ten i start
questioning everyone yeah yeah
exactly exactly
and also as a uni student you try to get
drunk as efficiently as you can because
you don't have the [ __ ] money from
traffic jobs right
so i mean it was still a student night
but i didn't want to spend money to get
a drink so
had like [ __ ] four five six beers
before going to the club and you know as
a student you
i always had like a bottle of like well
like half bottle of cheap vodka you know
just just
like actually just tell foreign just to
keep yourself drunk right because
there's no
there's no more efficiency there's a
tank full yeah yeah there's no more
efficient way to get drunk as a student
one pound shots or something you know
just ask for like one shot
it wasn't one pound shots in [ __ ]
bristol man i'll tell you that
of course this isn't [ __ ] swansea man
everything is one point yeah but like uh
so you i had this uh half bottle of
vodka cheap vodka
probably like check off vodka it wasn't
spun off
and uh so we get we get to the club and
we realize that people are checking
are the bouncers are checking pockets
for anyone like in my situation who's
trying to sneak in
some bottle of vodka and i was like well
[ __ ] um i have to dispose of this
somehow
and by this point by the time i've
gotten to
this club it was already half drunk so
it was like
about a quarter litre vodka left and my
mate goes just hide it around the corner
next to the dumpster in case you want it
and i'm like
i gotta i got a better idea i'm gonna do
a pro gamer move
and i [ __ ] down the thing
so i [ __ ] downed this thing right uh
and i was like
i can't feel it i'm a [ __ ] pro right
five minutes you'll be fine yeah yeah
yeah exactly so
get in the club completely fine not even
drunk go go to the bar get my first
drink i'm like
having a [ __ ] amazing time and so i'm
in the middle of the dance floor
and like it just it just like there
wasn't a transition right i
you you know how sometimes you have like
a cool transition where just like you
can
you go you go from merry to drunk to
absolutely pissed
i went from like tier one to tier 10 in
like
the matter of the second hitchcock zoom
it's like boom i was thinking on the
dance floor and then i was like
[ __ ] everything's spinning everything's
spinning and
so i'd never been this drunk in my life
probably and i was this drunk
for the first time in my life in a club
and i'm just like i'm i
am a smart boy i am an electronic
engineer i am not going to let anyone
know
that i'm [ __ ] drunk
so without talking to my friends or
anyone i [ __ ] go to the nearest table
i could and uh it was like right
opposite the bar
and like i was the room was like [ __ ]
spinning around me
it took every ounce of energy to not
like topple over
but i somehow managed to get to this
table and not topple over and i'm just
like
i'm going to wait this out i thought i
could wait this out right so
um there was a bottle of water we'll fix
it yeah yeah yeah so so
um i sit on this table and there's just
this glass of water there right
and because the room is [ __ ] spinning
around me i just [ __ ] stare at this
water
i i like you like this is me using a
hundred percent of my brain this is like
this is like the mind expands moment
like i can game the system nobody
nobody's gonna ever know i'm [ __ ]
drunk so
i'm [ __ ] staring at this water
[ __ ] intently just trying to keep my
focus on something
so the room just stopped spinning around
me and i could just and i could just
like focus
on something yeah and then five minute
passes
and so i i feel the tap on my shoulder
and it's the [ __ ] bouncer
and he's like mate you gotta [ __ ] go
out and i was like why what have i done
i've just been sitting here and
he's like you've been sitting there for
an hour and a half staring at that glass
of water holy [ __ ]
so what felt like five minutes i uh
i had been just like sitting like
[ __ ] eyes open staring at this glass
of water for an hour and a half just
doing
this sounds almost like time travel yeah
yeah yeah you did
god will discover he channeled his monk
waves yeah
and time flies he went into a sale i
used to uh
you know i totally forgot existed but i
used to like take a canteen in
well there's a little like like an old
general yeah
i like the little like twister big brain
they they can't find it
if you like i just like attach it to my
like pants like inside
your pants yeah just put it in my pants
pretty sure that's how
people had guns put in my pants and then
whenever you like order a vodka you just
like
top it up put it in yeah you're a
student and this looks like three pounds
and i was like oh my god this is
rubbery yeah like then because you know
if i spent more than like ten dollars a
night i'd be like i'm broke yeah yeah of
course so i had to find ways so i would
just fill up a canteen full of vodka and
then i asked my friends they want some
too and i just you know
everyone loved me they were like what a
role model can make my double vodka into
a quadruple vodka
that was like the life hack in
university yeah yeah no one else i knew
did it everyone thought was a weirdo for
buying a canteen well god i thought he
was like i've
just just been bringing it no one's done
this have you ever done that where
you've figured out something on your own
and you found out that like everyone's
been doing it on the internet and you
feel like a
[ __ ] loser you figure out something
you're like i'm so [ __ ] smart yeah
and you find everyone else who's done it
he's like that question i'm the only one
it's my original idea every time
unheard of